[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: We have a dream
that one day all companies will
compete not only to be
the best in the world,
but the best for the world.
Others share this
dream and have begun
to turn the dream
into a community.
This community signed a
Declaration of Interdependence
and invited others to join them.
Now more than 900
companies from 29 countries
are turning our community
into a global movement
to redefine success in business.
B Corporations use
the power of business
to solve social and
environmental problems.
An eyewear company that
disrupts an industry
and serves the poor.
A food service company that
serves over one million meals
to low income public
school students every week.
A manufacturer that goes
green and helps workers
move from welfare to a career.
An online bookseller
that recycles
used books and funds local
libraries and global literacy.
An outdoor apparel company
that stewards the environment.
An ice cream company that
maintains its mission
post-sale.
B Corp is a certification
that helps consumers identify
these changemakers and
investors make money and make
a difference.
As a community we are passing
laws across the country,
creating a new kind
of company that
serves society and shareholders.
We are leading a global movement
of people using business
as a force for good.
Join us.
Be the change.
[END MUSIC PLAYING]
HOST: Good afternoon.
Thank you guys so
much for joining us.
We have a really
exciting plan for you
to talk to some members
of B Corporations
and learn a little
bit more about B Lab
and what B Corporations do.
We're thrilled to be here,
we've had a really nice morning,
and we're so excited that you
took time out of your busy day
to come and hear
some of our speakers.
So as the video pointed out,
certified B Corporations
are corporations that
meet higher standards
of social and environmental
performance, transparency,
and legal accountability.
As of January 2014 there are
more than 920 certified B
Corporations from over
60 countries, industries,
and 29 countries.
20 states including
Delaware have
enacted Benefit
Corporation legislation
and over 400
companies have adopted
this new corporate form.
More than 15,000 businesses are
measuring what matters using B
Lab's B Impact Assessment,
and more than 100 investors
and fund managers representing
over $6 billion in assets
across 30 countries are using
B Analytics and GIRS ratings,
or G-I-R-S ratings, which we
hope that Andrew here will help
explain a little bit more.
So this is Andrew Kassoy.
He is the co-founder
of B Lab, and he
spent 16 years in the
private equity business
prior to founding B Lab.
We also have with
Mike Brady, who
is the president
and CEO of Greyston.
And we also have
here Anjali Kumar,
who is the general
counselor at Warby Parker.
I'm going to just start off by
telling you a little bit more
about their careers and how they
came to either work at B Lab
or work for B Corporations.
And then we have a
series of questions
that we've prepared
to ask them and we'll
open up the floor for any of
your questions at the end,
if that's OK.
So prior to founding
B Lab, Andrew
spent 16 years in the private
equity business as a partner
at Amnesty Real
Estate Capital, which
is an affiliate of MSE
Capital, the $12 billion
investment vehicle
for Michael Dell,
and as the Managing Director
in Credit Suisse First Boston's
Private Equity department--
that's a mouthful--
a founding partner of DLJ
Real Estate Capital Partners
and president of its
international business.
He's a board member of
Echoing Green and adviser
to the NYU Reynolds Fellows
program and a member of the US
Working Group of the G8 Social
Impact investing task force.
He's a former board member
of the Freelancers Union,
and he hails from Boulder,
Colorado and graduated
with distinction
from Stanford, where
he was a Truman Scholar and
President's Award winner.
He is a Henry Crown Fellow
at the Aspen Institute.
Andrew is now living in New
York City with his wife Margot
and two sons, one
nine and one seven.
So that is quite a busy life.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
We're so excited to have you.
ANDREW KASSOY:
Thanks for having me.
HOST: Mike Brady is
the President and CEO
of Greyston Bakery
which is probably
one of the awesomest
bakeries ever--
MIKE BRADY: That's
enough, I think.
That's fine.
ANDREW KASSOY: That's
all you need to know.
HOST: --founded the
best bakery ever.
So Greyston Bakery is actually
building on its 30th year,
and it is really and
truly a heritage model
for social enterprise.
Michael served on the board
of directors of the Greyston
Foundation before
being named president
of the bakery in January 2012.
Prior to joining Greyston he
launched the first incubator
in the country dedicated
to organic food
production and distribution.
He's also a founding partner
at BAO Food and Drink,
a local food manufacturer
in New York City.
He spent over 20 years in
strategy and management
positions identifying and
exploiting new business
opportunities in high-growth
and transitional industries,
has a true passion for
social entrepreneurism,
and is using the
power of business
to solve social issues that
are fundamental to his work
at Greyston.
Michael's also a
business adviser
to the American Sustainable
Business Council,
helping to promote policies
for a more sustainable economy.
He received his MBA from the
Warren School of Business
and lives in New York City with
his wife and also two boys.
MIKE BRADY: Trying that, yeah.
HOST: Many of you
know Anjali Kumar.
She is an idea
acupuncturist, which
means that she ignites
ideas in others.
ANJALI KUMAR: I'm also a lawyer.
It's not as fun to say.
HOST: But we decided
idea acupuncturist
is her formal title.
A designer, traveler,
writer, and explorer.
In more official terms, she's
currently the General Counsel
and Head of Social
Innovation at Warby Parker,
a transformative lifestyle brand
that offers fabulous designer
eyewear for those of us that are
fashionable at a revolutionary
price while making sure
to lead a way for socially
conscious business.
Anjali used to be Senior
Counsel at Google New
York-- we miss her-- where she
was a commercial or product
attorney on areas ranging
from Google X to advertising
technology to YouTube.
She also curated the At
Google speaker series,
which is why I'm
slightly nervous,
bringing Googlers
around the globe face
to face with some of today's
most prominent thinkers.
Prior to being at Google,
Anjali was General Counsel
at the Acumen Fund, an attorney
at Sherman and Sterling,
and led strategic planning
at the Robin Hood Foundation.
She's currently also an Adjunct
Professor at Fordham University
and served as a board member
of the Issue Project Room.
There's more.
She's working on a book
called "From Google to God"
as well as a feature-length
documentary based on the book
and in collaboration with
Russell Simmons and Madeleine
Sackler.
She is also the co-creator with
Questlove of the forthcoming
web series, "Questlove Presents
Slightly Reserved with Anjali
Kumar"-- which is awesome--
which will appear on the "Fast
Company" website.
She's designed a handbag
line featured in "Vogue"
and on "Sex and the City".
She earned her BA
Biomedical Ethics
from Brown University and her
JD from Boston University School
of Law, and she lives in New
York City with her husband
Atul and her daughter Zia.
So we are psyched
to have you here.
Thank you so much for coming.
ANJALI KUMAR: Thanks
for inviting me back.
HOST: If we could just
please welcome them all.
[APPLAUSE]
HOST: When you're dealing
with such accomplished people,
their bios are incredible.
So thank you for hanging
with us while we asked that.
ANDREW KASSOY: Somebody
should go online and verify--
ANJALI KUMAR: It's all BS.
HOST: We should live
fact check those bios.
All right, so I just
want to start off
talking a little
bit more in depth
about why B Corps are
important and really
opening up the discussion
to really investigate
why it is that we're
here and focused
on really promoting
B Corporations.
Let's start off with Andrew.
Why is being a B Corp important
to you as an individual,
and why do you think it's
important to consumers
and the broader community?
ANDREW KASSOY: So
I'm going to give
a slightly different
answer than these two
because I don't actually
work at a B Corp. I work
at B Lab, which is
the nonprofit that's
kind of helping to promote
the B Corp movement.
So the sort of personal
version of that
is, there were three
of us that started
B Lab about 6 and 1/2 years ago.
All of us came from
the private sector.
So you read my bio, I was
a pretty uninteresting
private equity investor doing
pretty traditional investing.
But my two partners have
had much sexier careers.
They started and built
a footwear and apparel
business called And One.
They made like really cool shoes
and trash-talking t-shirts that
said "if I give you
$5 will you go home?"
and stuff like that that people
wore on-- or less politically
correct, "Your game is as
ugly as your girlfriend"--
that people wore like
on basketball courts.
And anyway, they turned
that into a $250 million
brand that outcompeted
Nike on a lot of things.
And they did it by
having a lot of passion,
but also by building a business
that had a phenomenal culture.
And so the three
of us, at the time
that they were selling
their business,
they went through a
experience of having a venture
investor who didn't really
care about much other
than just making
as much money as
possible off of the business.
And so the business got sold
to the highest bidder, who
was the bidder who cared
the least about all
the mission-driven things that
they did as a business, all
of the culture that
they'd created,
the really high standards
for manufacturing
they had in developing world
markets, stuff like that,
and saw all of
that stuff go away.
And so for them, it was
about trying to figure out
how we can help businesses
that care about something other
than just making money.
Entrepreneurs, people
who want to make money
but do good at the same time.
And for me, it
was the experience
of being in the
traditional capital markets
and seeing the way investors
think more and more and more
short term, which
leads them to care only
about making as much money in
their investments in a business
as quickly as they
possibly can, and trying
to externalize every
other cost on to society,
all the bad stuff.
And thinking that there's
got to be a different way
to build a marketplace
that supports businesses
so that they actually
create long-term value
both for their shareholders
and their stakeholders.
So that's why I
wanted to start B Lab.
A lot more interesting
is the entrepreneurs
who've actually started and
built the businesses themselves
that are changing the way
we all think about success
in business.
HOST: That's great.
And why do you think that this
is the most effective model
for social progress?
ANDREW KASSOY: Well,
it's not by itself,
but I think what's
important to say,
maybe, is that we've come
to a point in society
where we're faced with some
huge social and environmental
challenges, and a lot
of those challenges
can't be solved simply through
kind of traditional means
like nonprofits and government.
It's not that those
aren't really important,
they're necessary, but they're
insufficient to solving
some of our biggest challenges.
And the reason for
that is that they're
inherently limited
in their ability
to scale, to attract
capital, to attract talent.
And business makes
up 75% or 80% of GDP.
So either business is going
to be part of the problem,
or it's going to be
part of the solution.
And what we've seen is this
incredible-- particularly
amongst younger people--
but this incredible
outpouring of entrepreneurship,
of people wanting
to use business
to create change.
And so our feeling
has been, there
are some impediments
to that, most of which
are just kind of like cultural.
People just aren't used
to thinking about business
as a tool for positive
social change.
And that means that
there's not all the market
infrastructure built up.
There's not the information.
There's no way to
tell the difference
between a good company
and just good marketing.
And companies know-- you guys
know this-- companies know
that consumers care
and the people who
come to work at
their companies care
a ton about how
companies behave.
And so more and more
companies market
themselves as being green
or responsible or social
or whatever it is.
And it's hard to
tell the difference.
And so our instinct
originally was,
we need some
organizing principles
so that everybody
knows the difference
between a good company
and good marketing,
can identify those companies,
and then support them,
whether it's going
to work at them,
or starting them,
or buying from them.
And there's huge power
in all of those companies
then being able to get
together and speak collectively
with one voice.
HOST: That's a good point,
and I think specifically
the point around
it being so easy
to market yourself as being
a responsible company.
We've seen a huge surge in just
marketing around sustainability
and responsibility and
renewal, and we're giving back
to the community, and
part of our profits.
In starting Greyston, Mike,
why was it important for you
to make sure that you
were a B Corp versus any
of the other social programs
you could have done,
or even marketing
efforts you could
have done to be good
for the community?
MIKE BRADY: Yeah.
I need to be clear.
Greyston was started 30 years
ago by an amazing visionary
entrepreneur named
Bernie Glassman, when
and he started it with
the concept of a business
being able to
support a community
and giving back, in an
age 30 years ago when
that language and a
double bottom line
was not even thought of.
And I encourage everyone
to look up Bernie.
He has a long history as a
leader in socially engaged
Buddhism, and it's a great
story, probably a little bit
more than we can tell here.
I joined two years
ago, and I think
one of the interesting
tidbits is--
it's been so long that
it's off my bio-- I used
to work at a company called
Fast Search out of Norway.
There may be people in this
room that are familiar with it,
but it eventually grew
and was sold to Microsoft
as their Mindshare business.
At that point I began to look
at social entrepreneurship
and the importance of it, and
the importance of our dollars
going to companies that
actually share values
with my own values.
And I had the good fortune to
come across Greyston, which
is 25 minutes north on
the MTA, and I said,
this is a place I'd like
to get involved with.
And I find myself
now leading it.
It's been two years.
At the same time, New
York state had just about
passed legislation to allow
for Benefit Corporation status,
and I had been exposed
to it through other types
of businesses, my
other incubator
that you had mentioned.
It was at that
point that I said,
this is an opportunity
for Greyston
to take another
leadership position.
We had taken a leadership
position 30 years ago.
We need to take a
leadership in New York state
and we need to be a voice that
says, the model must change.
And there's a lot
that goes into that.
Andrew hit on a
couple of the pieces,
but it's the marketplace
that we're all collectively
a part of, and how can I
support my fellow B Corps,
how can they support me, how
can we get the message out
in meetings and opportunities
like this to say,
as consumers you need
to put your money
and look towards--
whether it be B
Corps or at least organizations
that share your values.
Because if you look at the way
the economy's working today,
it doesn't take you too long
to think, something's askew.
And the business that accounts
for that large portion of GDP
is contributing to it.
And if we don't look
for ways to change it,
we're going to continue
to spiral down.
And I don't mean to
be overly depressing,
but we really need to
think about the fact
that if we were all to fly to
California and those of you
watching from the Bay Area, and
got off the plane and everyone
there was living in
poverty, and everyone there
couldn't eat what they
wanted for food, that's
still 12 million people
less than those people
living under poverty in
our country right now,
47 million people that
don't know how they're
going to afford their next meal.
That seems like
a problem for us.
So at Greyston we're
a small bakery.
To give you context,
though, we're
not sitting around baking cakes.
One of the great organizations
in this country is Ben
and Jerry's.
For 23 years we've
been providing brownies
to Ben and Jerry's,
30,000 pounds a day,
twelve-hour shifts of
hard work, of baking.
Greyston's model
that we're known for
is called open hiring.
Anyone that comes to the
front door of our bakery,
we give a job to.
No questions asked.
And there needs to be
more models like that.
And that's what I hope,
through the Benefit Corporation
movement, through
conversations like this,
through working with Andrew
to think about employment,
that a greater impact can be
made just from the community
that we're in in Yonkers
to a much broader
community, a global community.
HOST: That's incredible.
As you mentioned, you've been
doing business since 1982.
How do you feel, since
Greyston's been in business,
that the social enterprise
landscape has changed?
MIKE BRADY: There
was none, right?
30 years ago.
These visionaries--
there's a handful of them
in their companies
that have survived,
the Ben and Jerry's,
the Seventh Generations,
the Greyston's-- had
an amazing vision,
and they had to overcome
naysayers left and right that
said, why are you
considering this?
And then it still happens today.
I just heard a conversation
10 minutes ago,
like business has
a responsibility
to the environment.
They have a responsibility to
the community they operate in.
It needs to own up to
that responsibility.
And that's what these
types of founders
30 years ago are doing.
Everyone in this room and
watching and the people that
are interested in are now
taking note, which is great.
What I hope in 30 years from
now the social enterprise term
has now disappeared,
it's run its cycle,
and every organization would
think back to say, what?
You weren't
considering environment
with the way you
ran your business?
You weren't considering
your employees' welfare
or the welfare of the community
when you ran your business?
That just seems crazy.
And that's what needs to change
in some time period soon.
HOST: Definitely.
Well, companies
such as yourselves,
and getting into some of the
work Warby Parker is doing,
are really disrupting the
way that business is done,
and even the way that
consumers think about the way
that business is done
and should be done.
Why do you think it's
important to Warby Parker
to be a Benefit Corporation?
ANJALI KUMAR: So we are a
certified B Lab corporation.
We're actually a C
Corp, a Delaware C Corp,
and we haven't changed
our legal status.
That option's only been
available since the summertime,
when the legislation changed.
And I think, for us, a lot of
the reason it was important
was because of the community
of like-minded folks
that we found within
the B Lab family.
The idea that you can do
well and do good in the world
is not necessarily
a new one, but it's
something that was really
important for our founders
to find that kind
of shared vision.
And I think when they met Andrew
and the team over at B Lab,
when they first started
the company, it was like,
oh, they get it, this is
what we're trying to do.
And we're not crazy
for having this idea
that we can be this
transformative lifestyle brand
offering prescription
eyewear for $95
and disrupt this industry.
We can do that and we can
make a lot of money doing it,
hopefully, and be
really successful,
but we can also have
an impact on the world
in a really meaningful way.
And so having that shared value
system with the folks at B Lab,
and then also just
the community of folks
that they bought
around this movement
has been really important,
I think, to Warby.
HOST: So how do you
think that technology
has played a role in
Warby Parker's success,
but also in just
highlighting the work
that Warby Parker is doing in
giving back to the community?
ANJALI KUMAR: I think it's
been absolutely critical.
Without technology there would
be no Warby Parker success,
frankly, because-- I
don't know if all of you
are familiar with the
story of Warby Parker,
but just really
briefly, the industry
that we're out to disrupt
is a really longstanding,
pretty entrenched
industry where there
is one company,
essentially, that
owns the entire ecosystem
from soup to nuts,
so they own everything from
the eyewear-only brands, things
like Persol or Oakley
or Oliver Peoples-- they
own all of those.
They have exclusive licenses
on a lot of the fashion brands
that you might wear, so like
your favorite eyewear fashion
brand, whether it's
Prada or DKNY or Polo.
They also own the
distribution channels, so
everything from a Pearle
Vision to a Sunglass Hut.
They own the-- it
keeps going-- they
own the in-store kind of optical
shops like Target Optical,
Walmart, et cetera.
And then they also own the
second-largest vision insurance
plan in the States.
So when you look at
that entire ecosystem
and realize that's all owned
by one company, Luxottica,
it's not surprising
why your glasses, which
are an 800-year-old
piece of technology,
cost more than
your Android phone.
It starts becoming a little
clearer why that might be
the case, because
these are ultimately--
they're really cute, I think I
look great in these glasses--
but they are ultimately
acetate and a couple-- I know,
I look really good in
them, right?-- acetate,
a couple metal screws,
and some glass.
It's really not that
advanced technology
that should be justifying
that price point.
So when Warby Parker set out to
disrupt this massive industry,
without access to those
distribution channels
it would've been virtually
impossible to actually do that.
So without technology, without
the Googles of the world,
without the
Internet, there would
have been no way to actually
go direct to the consumer
and do that.
So I think from our perspective,
social innovation really
starts with that, with
creating a high-quality product
of prescription
eyewear, something
that people need in their
lives to actually function
at a competitive price
point of what it should--
it's not a low-cost
price point, it's really
what glasses should cost.
It's just that you've
been overpaying
for them for all this time.
So here's what it should
cost, and they also
happen to be fashionable and all
these other wonderful things.
And oh yeah, on
top of that we also
give back when we sell glasses.
So that's sort of our
tertiary messaging.
HOST: That's great.
Thank you for that context.
It's so important.
I don't think many of us
realize that it's basically
one corporation that
manages every single aspect
of the vision industry.
That's amazing, down
to the insurance.
So given that, that's a
lot of obstacles to face.
What do you think
specifically, in terms
of working with Google,
one of the things
that we've been discussing
here over the last two quarters
internally while promoting
B Corps at Google,
is how many B Corporations
are actually using Google
technology or Google apps in
order to run their business.
So I'm going to start
with you and then
kind of go down the line.
How do you feel that
specifically using
Google technology has
been useful to you,
and what are some areas that
you think would be more useful
or are areas for development
in terms of using technology,
or ways that Google could help?
ANJALI KUMAR: My wish list?
This is exciting.
I never had this access
when I worked here,
so that's kind of--
I wish I'd known
I was going to be
asked this question.
I would have thought
about it more.
I would say, in terms
of my day to day,
it's absolutely instrumental.
We are on apps, we
use Gmail and Docs,
if they had switched us
back to other products I
don't know what I
would have done.
I don't think I
could have functioned
after being at Google for six
years and using all the apps.
It's absolutely part
of my day to day.
I don't feel like I left Google.
I was joking about
this with my colleagues
earlier, that I interact
with Google every single day,
constantly, whether
it's work or personally,
so I don't feel
like I ever left.
So I think for our
business it's been
absolutely part of the
basis of how we function
and how we run our business.
I need to think about
your second question--
HOST: We'll go right back--
ANJALI KUMAR: I'm going
to send you guys a list.
I'm collecting ideas.
I think it's been
incredibly powerful,
and just being searchable,
and the ads certainly
are a huge part of how we
market to our consumers.
So keep doing what you're doing.
HOST: So obviously Warby Parker
is a very different environment
than Greyston.
How have you been able
to leverage technology
to help promote the
history of Greyston
and what you're doing now?
And specifically,
are there any ways
that some of the apps that we
have running around can help?
MIKE BRADY: Yeah.
I think it's probably
better or easier
to answer it as what the
challenges are for us.
And the challenge
ties to a lot of what
Andrew was talking about.
But where Greyston
will stand out
amongst our peers in social
enterprise and leading
the way is through more
transparency and more
accountability and
access to information,
which are all things that Google
is excellent at providing.
So Andrew mentioned the impact
study and the impact analysis.
We do quite well on that.
Helping people to understand
how we do well and why,
and what they can do
at their own businesses
to copy what Greyston has done,
or to leverage pieces of what
Greyston has done, or to
understand parts of Gresyton.
And it's somewhat
self-fulfilling, of course,
because then you'll
learn about Greyston,
and by the way, online you can
buy some delicious brownies.
And that's why Greyston is
really an interesting place,
because we have a product
that most people like.
And the keywords
around brownies are
"more than I care to spend."
But some keywords around social
entrepreneurship, mission,
open hiring,
alleviation of poverty,
are more available to me.
So there's a lot of
interest on my part
and I think around what
Google can provide around,
how do I market that?
How do I get people to
be aware of Greyston?
How do more people come
in contact with us?
So that's on one
end of the business.
And then the other end is, I
work with a population of folks
that-- it's very hard for me
prior to working with them,
and I might suggest,
although I don't
want to paint with
a broad brush,
that many people in the
audience who are watching,
can appreciate the
challenges of the lifestyle
that people that
work at Greyston
or come through the Greyston
system, have to deal with.
And they can't afford a
phone, but they need a phone.
And they can afford unlimited
data, but they want it, right?
I can't text my
workers and let them
know that we're down because we
had a snowstorm or something,
because they don't want to
have to incur that charge.
Tools to allow me to have access
and work with a low income
population, that are affordable
and become ubiquitous and are
easily accessible, are critical.
And they're often not thought
of because there isn't money
there, and that's a problem.
That's a problem.
HOST: And I think, as
you started to say,
some of the things that you
do, like your open hire policy,
those are all part of your
model and your approach
towards the way that you
want to run Greyston.
Do you think that
being a B Corporation
presents unique challenges
that non-B Corps don't face,
and if so, what are they
for Greyston currently?
MIKE BRADY: I don't think
they're our unique challenges.
I mean, the work-- it comes
up, obviously, there's
some reporting
requirements, there's
some elements to being
a B Corp, but these
are things that I believe
a business just should do.
And that's my value as the
leader of Greyston now,
but I don't frankly
understand other leaders that
don't appreciate at least
bringing elements of that
to their business.
It's very easy for
everyone in this room
to think about, OK, I'm buying
this product, and as a business
I'm sourcing office
supplies, let's say.
Why wouldn't I source
those from an organization
that I know shares
my values and is
treating the
environment properly?
It's just a small one piece
of your business to do that.
Reporting on that in my
Benefit Corporation report
is not a burden.
And the ROI on this,
another challenge,
but I think the long term
ROI on this-- and Ben
and Jerry's is the same
way, and Ben and Jerry's is
owned by Unilever--
they are the same way.
This population,
the Millennials,
will be buying from companies
based on these values.
So we'll have a competitive
advantage by doing this,
and leaders that don't
see that are shortsighted
and have short-termism as
one of their biggest issues.
And I'm sure Andrew
can go into that.
But I don't see any burden
from being a B Corp,
or doing a Benefit
Corporation status.
HOST: I see you
agreeing on this.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah, I
think it's absolutely true.
I think if anything, it
helps-- the process is
so rigorous to actually
be certified as a B Lab--
it's not like you fill out a
form and then you're certified.
It really is quite a
rigorous auditing process,
for lack of a better word.
And we were already
doing those things,
and it's what we want
to do, but in a way
it highlights best practices
for our company, right?
So it might point
out things that
are like, oh, we didn't
think about that,
that's a great idea.
And that's a way for us
to be more sustainable
or for us to push a
little bit on that issue,
or as we start having
damaged frames,
what do we do with them?
We should think about
recycling them and coming up
with an interesting
plan around that.
And it just sort of
helps test our thinking
and push us to do more.
But it's things that are
already within the company
ethos and the DNA
of Warby Parker.
And I think of so many
companies that are B Labs,
or not-- maybe they're
not certified--
but they share that desire
to do good in the world,
or to not do more
harm in the world.
So I don't think of it
as burdensome either.
I think of it as very much just
helping us stay on our toes.
HOST: That's wonderful.
And I think just to kind of
transition over to Andrew,
Anjali mentioned the
certification process
and how rigorous that
vetting process is
and the auditing process is.
Maybe you can talk
to us a little bit
about how you find companies
and how they find you,
and what the auditing
process is like.
ANDREW KASSOY: Yep.
So to be clear, B Lab
is this nonprofit.
We run a certification, and
the brand of the certification
is called a B Corp.
It's a little bit
like if you know fair trade
certification, B Corp is that,
but for whole companies.
And so for a company to
get certified as a B Corp,
it has to do two things.
One, it has to meet a minimum
set of social and environmental
performance standards.
So we created a
rating system, which
we can get to the
technology of that,
because there's a bunch of
really great opportunities
there.
But we basically
built a rating system
that measures the impact
of a business on all
of its stakeholders, not
just its shareholders,
but the community, the
environment, its workers,
its consumers, its supply
chain, all that kind of stuff.
The second thing is that the
company makes a commitment
to expand who it considers when
it makes decisions beyond just
considering the value for
that particular decision
on its shareholders,
but to consider
all of its stakeholders
when it makes decisions.
And those two things
together allow the company
to get certified
as a B Corporation
and join this community
of like-minded companies,
and then together to speak
with collective voice.
It's hard to get
certified, though.
You have to do real
work, as Anjali
said, to go through
that process.
And part of it,
for every company,
is a learning experience.
As good as lots
of companies are,
whether it's these two or
Patagonia or Ben and Jerry's,
they all, when they go
through that process,
realize there are
things that they've
been focused on
that they do great,
and there are lots of other
places where they fall down.
And so part of that
experience of going
through the
certification process
is meant to also help
everybody meet them
when they are, and then
help lift all boats.
And one of the
interesting things
that's happened as
a result of that
is there are now
15,000 companies that
are using that tool that
they've used to get certified
as B Corps-- there are 15,000
companies who have just
gone online and started to use
that tool in order to measure
their own social and
environmental impact
and improve it.
They might not even be
ready to become B Corps.
They might not be
quite good enough yet.
Or they might be good
enough but just say,
you know what, we don't need
to wear it on our sleeve.
We really just want to use
it as an internal tool.
But more and more
companies are doing that.
And that's a huge
opportunity to effect,
through their leadership
and their transparency,
it's a huge opportunity for
them to inspire thousands
and eventually hundreds
of thousands of businesses
to measure and improve
their impact in the world.
Google could go through
that B Impact Assessment
and probably learn
some great stuff.
You'd probably see some
things that the company does
incredibly well and find
some other things that
would be a great learning
experience for the company
to consider as it
continues to scale.
So that's what's involved
in becoming a B Corp.
One of the things I think
that's important to say
is when people like
Greyston started
thinking about this idea 30
years ago, of using business
as a force for good, they
were like wandering around
in the wilderness.
There were only a few of them.
And they were pretty
out there in terms
of thinking about that.
They were in your classic
model of disruptive technology.
They were mostly
dismissed as oh, that's
cute, because they
just weren't that many.
And Mike's downplaying the
impact, the actual impact
of what that business
has done over 30 years.
Not just in Yonkers, New
York, in taking people
who are coming out of prison
and turning their lives around
by giving them jobs
and training them
and then sending them
off to have real careers.
But also the repetition of
that model by other people
who've been totally inspired
by it all over the world
changing the way they
think about work.
Thirty years later
here we are, and there
are more and more
mainstream businesses
who've seen that and
recognized that they
can do business and
do well while having
a huge positive impact
in doing something
in line with their values.
And so Anjali also played down
the impact of Warby Parker
is not just on their practices,
and things like a new recycling
plan for glasses, or how
they treat their own workers,
or how they think about
making life a hell of a lot
better for consumers
than it has been
by making glasses
cost $400 less.
But it's also that every time
I sell a pair of glasses,
an organization in
the developing world
gets a pair of glasses to start
a business where they sell
those glasses to people who
could otherwise never afford
a pair of glasses.
And so they're
changing economies
throughout the developing world
through those partnerships,
what they're giving away.
And that's a mainstream
business that's got--
I don't know how much,
but let's say $100 million
of venture capital money
from venture capital funds
that you've all heard of.
So they're not running
a cute little thing.
They're at that
next stage that's
beyond people dismissing,
but people actually being
threatened because they're
taking on-- through a totally
mainstream, quickly
scaling business--
they're taking on the accepted
order of how business is done.
That's pretty threatening.
And I think that there's
a-- sorry to go on,
but I do think there's
a ton of power, then,
in them having a
family to lean on
in doing that, that
can tell those stories.
And that's part of what the B
Corp community is all about.
At some point, another five
or 10 or 25 years from now,
that'll just be how
business is done.
All businesses will be competing
to be best for the world,
not just best in the world.
HOST: You speak and I
have to take a moment
to absorb what you said,
because it's so impactful.
It's bigger, I think,
than most of us
take time to really focus on.
What are some ways
that you feel--
we were talking a little
bit before the talk started
about privilege, and how
we're not even aware of just
how where we're born
or where we work
gives us privilege sometimes.
We just don't take the
time to think about it.
Working at a place
like Google, where
we're surrounded by so
much beauty and food,
and we don't think about
hunger on a daily basis.
I know it's not necessarily
at the forefront of my mind
as I'm passing by a
microkitchen stocked with food.
What are some ways
that you think
young people such as ourselves
that work at companies
like Google can contribute to
the B Corporation community,
to B Lab, to B Corporations,
small businesses,
or even to just promote
knowledge around the community?
I'll start with Anjali.
ANJALI KUMAR: I think
there's a lot of ways.
I think starting with being
a conscious consumer, that's
always a great place to start.
That's a really easy way to
start, voting with your dollars
and spending money at companies
that share that value system
if that's something
that you hold dear.
And I would think an audience
full Googlers, that there's
a reason that you're here, and
it's beyond just the free food.
It's really because of the core
value system of this company.
It's certainly why
I was here and why
I was really proud to
be here for so long.
So I think starting with
that is a great way.
I was thinking a little bit
more about your question
about what I would
want from Googlers
and what my ask would be.
And it's not really
a technology ask.
It's more like a "help
me solve this problem"
ask, which is, you think
about the number of people
in the world that don't
have access to glasses.
It's a billion people, right?
That's like a full 15%
of the world's population
that does not have access
to prescription eyewear that
need it.
And that's a staggering
statistic, right?
And that's a
distribution challenge.
If we could actually get
classes into the hands of all
those people who need it, they
could increase their earning
potential by 20%.
What a low-cost poverty
alleviation tool.
We don't need to give
them information,
we don't need to give
them all this other stuff.
We can, but let's
start with glasses.
It's a really simple tool to
help people change their lives
in a really meaningful way.
And again, it's a
distribution problem.
I can't get glasses into
all these folks' hands
because I can't get to them.
Help me figure that out.
That would be amazing.
Let's get glasses to everybody.
So if somebody
here wants to help
me think about
those problems, that
would be amazing, and help
me find those partners of how
we do this in a responsible
way, in a sustainable way,
not just in pure charity
and just giving them away
and disrupting local
economies and businesses.
But really creating a
sustainable solution
to that problem.
That would be incredible.
And so I think that's sort of my
big ask, but in a smaller way,
I think it's just start with
where you spend your money.
MIKE BRADY: Could I add
something real quickly?
I think buying with the dollar
is incredibly important, where
you spend your money.
Also we have such access
to information and policies
that are out there that
grassroots movements now
can have incredible impact.
Think about how our
government is operating
and how things are
passing in your state
and your local governments.
I have in the back of my
mind the Minimum Wage Act.
Form an opinion on that.
And when you have an opinion,
go out and speak about it,
and try to get those
things moved forward
to support those that need help
from others that perhaps are
privileged enough to have
opportunities to work
at an amazing place like this
after all your hard work.
HOST: Thank you.
It's a good point.
AUDIENCE: First of all,
that blondie is probably
one of the best things I've
ever had, so thank you so much.
MIKE BRADY: Eat more brownies.
That's another good thing.
AUDIENCE: But I'm glad
that you brought up
something like the Minimum Wage
ACT, because I wanted to ask,
for B Corps, what is the stance
when it comes to dabbling
in the public policy realm, and
how do you constrain yourself,
or what is the most effective
model that yo've found so far?
ANDREW KASSOY: Great question.
So I think it's funny.
Entrepreneurs run from
public policy and government
as fast as they
possibly can, and so
it's always this interesting
struggle of this huge community
of entrepreneurs who are running
these inspiring businesses
and, like it or not, businesses
affected in all kinds of ways
by public policy.
And so there has to be
some engagement there,
and so a lot of
times they look to us
to try to help play that
role, along with some other
organizations that are engaged
in this sustainable business
space and social
entrepreneurship.
The view we've
taken is, we don't
want to be a political
player, because we don't think
this idea of using business
as a force for good
is a left or a
right kind of idea.
I mean, if you're a liberal
you can get behind the idea
that we need business to
address a lot of problems
that we have because business
creates a lot of externalities.
If you're a free-market
conservative
you can get behind the idea that
what better tool than business
and free markets to solve some
of our biggest challenges?
So this is not political.
And so the approach we try
to take to public policy
has been all about enabling.
Let's do everything we can
to level the playing field,
to make sure that
businesses that actually
care about creating impact have
the same ability to compete.
So we've gotten legislation
passed in 20 states that's
actually created this corporate
form called the Benefit Corp.
It's basically a legal
version of a B Corp.
And the reason for doing
that was because there was
a huge impediment to
businesses is being able
to scale, which was
that corporate law says
that a business's obligation
is to maximize value
for its shareholders.
Well, if that's true, then
it's really hard for a business
to choose to consider
other things.
It's like actual legal
liability for the directors.
And so on the
public policy front,
we've tried to attack issues
like that, where it's not
about politics,
it's about enabling.
I think there are some
great opportunities
to think about how you tax
companies that are creating
measurable, quantifiable
benefit for society, not just
for their shareholders,
or how you tax
the investment in
those businesses.
It doesn't have to
be a political issue
on one side of the
aisle or the other,
but where we can support
these kinds of businesses
and incentivize more of
them to solve big problems.
HOST: That's a great question.
Thank you.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: I think Andy
might have touched
upon what I was
going to ask anyways,
but it seems like--
I was wondering
if there are publicly traded
companies that are B Corps,
and the reason I'm
asking is it seems
there's a natural tension
between the shareholders
wanting to maximize
profits, and then
the company wanting to
meet the B Corp standards
might have to give
up some profits
to get social and
environmental changes.
And we talk about impact and
getting large players to adopt,
so have you sensed this tension,
and what are some of the things
you're doing to bridge that gap?
ANDREW KASSOY: Great question.
I think Anjali can obviously
speak about this a lot,
because she works at a company
that's scaling and doing really
well even while keeping
all these things in mind.
There's no question
there's a tension there.
And that said,
there's no evidence
that companies that
consider their stakeholders
do worse, particularly
over the long term.
And there are some
studies that show actually
that they do better.
And it makes sense.
They retain talent better,
they avoid ridiculous risks
that they shouldn't be taking,
that are irresponsible,
because they're
more transparent.
They are able to
create more loyalty
with their consumers
and their supply chains.
So they do a lot of things that
allow them to create maybe more
value over the long term.
So I think that's a
really important thing.
That said, there's
a lot of education
to do of investors, particularly
in the public markets,
on that issue.
And one thing just about
technology that I think
is important to
say on this point.
We have a ton of data, but
we're running a nonprofit,
and we are certainly not--
we're not data geeks,
we don't know anything
about big data.
And one of the things that
we could really use help with
is thinking about how
to use all of the data
that we collect from
these 15,000 companies,
along with data that's out
there on other companies,
to start to make that case
in a much more powerful way.
So if you're a big data
engineer kind of a person
and wanted to spend some time
helping us try to figure that
out, that's one of the
most important things
if we want long
term growth here.
The last thing I would
say on that front
is, some company, some
public company someday
is going to become a
B Corp. It'll happen.
So maybe it ought to be Google.
HOST: That's a
really good point.
Get it in, grow the idea.
Thank you guys so
much for coming.
We know that you're
incredibly busy,
and we really appreciate
all of the information
that you shared with us and
all of the work that you do.
It's been an absolute
honor to have you here, so
thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]